very few insects are more detested than
the cockroach even the word itself can
be an insult
hey you cockroach get out of here so
let's say you've got cockroaches in your
home or your office or god forbid your
favorite restaurant and you decide
you're going to get rid of them here's
what you're up against the cockroach
doesn't really have a brain per se but
it has instinct and a ferocious desire
to survive and reproduce they're small
and can fit into cracks and crevices
roaches like this German Roach have
great peripheral vision thanks to some
hip looking wraparound eyes that curve
into its head their antennae detect food
and water as well as threatening odors
so the roach keeps its antenna clean
but it's their tails that form the front
line of the cockroach defense system
super sensitive hairs alert the roach
when you make your move and it takes off
it speeds up to 11 inches per second the
human equivalent of 93 miles an hour
Oh roaches want is food water and warmth
and your house is full of all three a
roach can go an entire month without
food in your home in one month can you
honestly say there won't be one leaky
faucet or one dirty dish to feed it can
the nightmare gets worse
cockroaches are ready to make more
cockroaches two months after birth
males fondle the ant any of other
roaches to determine if they're female
or not when he finds a female the male
secretes some sticky roach candy on its
back raises its wings and offers it to
its potential mate
the female starts to lap this up and get
stuck but she finally finds out she's
been had she drags the male around
eventually she settles down and they
mate
the female mates only once in her
lifetime but keeps enough sperm for
seven brews after 10 days and egg
capsule forms a month later cockroach
babies begin sprouting from the capsule
80% of the babies the ones that aren't
eaten by adults survive if you've got a
thousand cockroaches in your house in
six months that number can be ten
thousand you might not like them but
cockroaches are actually beneficial
they're important recyclers of dead and
decaying animals and plants and of the
four thousand wrote species only 1% are
considered pests any way you look at it
it's their world my friend you only live
in it